e dopo 5 minuti dall'ultimo viaggio
anche questa volta siamo arrivati
all'ennesimo blog di viaggi di porto con
me di qualche modo cerco sempre di
metterli nel mio zainetto esattamente
nella tasca più piccola questa prima di
partire volevo dirvi anche una
particolarità su questo viaggio nello
scorso blog avete visto romeo
sponsorizzato il adesso voi mi spiegate
come com'è possibile che a nasser
appiccicato sopra il telefono come avevo
fatto lo spot del mio tab per
rappresentarlo con lo spot non sense per
chi non lo sapesse il mio brand fa vj si
è legato agli sciani per la
pubblicazione di questi due prodotti
quindi il tab e il telefono che l'ha
pizzicato a tab un secondo fa per chi
non sapesse di cosa sto parlando
comunque quella fantomatica scatola dove
tra l'altro c'è il mio bel faccione e
dopo lo spot che ho fatto sul mio tab
cercherò di farne un altro mentre sono a
valenza quindi questi due ex me li porto
dove l'ho messo lo zaino il filo
direttamente nello zaino anzi questo qua
lo metto nel taschino quello che ci
siete anche voi
cercherò di fare una specie di spot come
l'altro quello da settimana scorsa però
valentia fatto questo questa la breve
introduzione ci vediamo direttamente al
mondo del viaggio quindi buone anziane
poi l'accompagnero senza dovevamo
prendere un aereo un pochetto pe canyon
è più grosso ordivano di casa mia
mattino ok base gli aerei i piccoli sono
quelli ieri normali questa piana aereo
che m volano seguite va bene alla città
la cintura caporali
in aereo se vi schiantate c'è questa
cosa può più vi salva la vita
la
[Musica]
quest'anno la partenza milano grigia
quando atterriamo è così
anche vestito
ma lo scenario non è assolutamente lo
stesso uguale a milano pioggia grigio
perché perché perché anche a madrid
perché perché perché
all
hai visto dove ti porta more al mattino
perché ogni volta che armi laser versa
origini la salvezza cagna esplica me il
bicchiere di salvezza catania e quindi
se tu parla alle nome completo oppure un
bicchiere di servizi pescaia salvezza
cagna cagna paradis finch imparano sotto
ospiti ma so propio d s ma poi guarda il
callo fra mta fuoco ti prego che belli
li piedi che schifo fra grazie reso
questo video un bel video
raga 100.000 like per i suoi piedi
[Musica]
ma che abbiamo
però qualche ragnetto e via via in via
da litri
va bene io io io ho delle buste che
iniziate abbiamo raschiato dobbiamo
raschiando vemos a raschiare grazie alla
loro azienda di magno perché dopo la
baia e ne ha mangiato tantissime
raschiava la schiava perché la baia
bisognerà schiare dalla padella aveva
sognassimo cioè camminava come uno
zombie arriva guardate come sveglio
adesso ecco ecco abbiamo preso delle
bici ci siamo fermati ci sono i bambini
e poi c'è lui c'è una persona che non
riesco a capire io nella mia vita non
l'ho mai capito un adulto vero e proprio
fa veramente mi stai attaccando un
palloncino dei viola alla bce a pelle
ma allora questa è una cosa fighissima
perché lorenzo è laggiù e quel puntino
lì lo vedete per niente cosa succede se
lui parla la giu io parlo la voce arriva
cioè fa tutta l'arcata e arriva qua e
incredibile ma esattamente dove sei caro
amico mio
porca vacca va che figata sei un
chilometro e ti sento come se fosse
vicinissimo
cioè lui sta parlando tanto almeno di
120 legano i palloncini al polso per
farmi sembrare molto più infanti giani
mostro 15 anni per cortesia questa
sarebbe una foto che potresti mentre su
instagram però è un video
dicevano che siamo al città dell'arte
della scienza di valentia
qua
tornerà appena nato
macchie che teneri che sono quello sono
io quando sei morto ma quello fa tornare
in realtà ragazza
cesto pulcino che passa vicino all'altra
e l'altro sgambetta che si è svegliato
senza riuscito a riprendere questa cosa
[Musica]
ora che abbiamo appena scoperto di avere
il cofano di tutto questo con una cagata
di piccione sul destro fa così difficile
aprì un cofano ha posto la seconda levi
afferma che il razzo vettore
[Musica]
ma ti pare che i parcheggi sono così ma
ne sei in grado di questo rapisce st
cacca di piccione davanti
[Musica]
che si diano
nella grande aiuto
ragazzi basta a youtube finito qua per
me lo chiedo che le cronache con guido
mi riprenderò a un po lorenzo che dilaga
e cavoli suoi così almeno io posso delle
cronache zare e le cronache zare edito
in santa pace bene raga sono entrato nel
bagno dell'ospitalità italiana della
motogp e nel bagno
qua c'è questo il ba nel cesso e sopra
il sesso c'è stata scritta ok ti occupi
di motogp e non di basket nba ma prova
lo stesso a far centro grazie cielo
numeri uno solo questa roba
io volevo chiudere questo blog però mi
perdo nelle cose come i bambini
spero che video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
ho fatto anche lo spot del mio von
quello che avevo detto all'inizio del
video uscirà tra poco nei prossimi video
io concludo poi vedo ragazzi ma
possibile io è la scienza siamo due poli
opposti bella ragazzi
[Musica]